welcome back to cbs this morning today
marks exactly
six months six months since a pro-trump
mob
stormed the u.s capitol we all remember
that day more than 500 people have been
arrested and hundreds of investigations
are still underway
so while some of the physical barriers
they've certainly come down around
capitol hill though mental scars remain
for many who work there including the
members of congress
in a story that you'll see here only on
cbs this morning
nicole killian introduces us to a group
of lawmakers
who have developed a shared bond as they
try to cope with what happened on that
awful day everybody
hearing the insurrectionists just the
pounding on the door
the capitol police were locking the
doors with us inside that's where i
realized
there was no way out hearing the shot
come from the speaker's lobby
and i just remember thinking oh my god
six months later the memories are still
vivid for representatives pramila
jayapal
veronica escobar susan wild and jason
crowe
who were among many members trapped in
the house gallery
january 6. how was the gallery group
formed
the very next day we had a caucus call
and i said something about being trapped
in the gallery i mean i think all of us
felt like we had been
forgotten up there and immediately
i got just dozens of texts
from people saying i was in the gallery
too some i knew
you know veronica was right next to me
so congresswoman jayapal started a tax
chain
that has evolved into a support group
with about two dozen lawmakers
what were some of those initial
conversations like for your group
there were a lot of tears there was a
lot of anger what kind of toll
has this taken on each of you personally
i was having some very violent
nightmares that were
deeply disturbing i lost my life partner
to suicide just about two years ago
i had thought i was
past the hardest part of that what i
found out after this
was that i hadn't even begun to deal
with that
it was this viral image of congresswoman
wilde and congressman crow that
triggered flashbacks for him
as an army ranger in iraq and
afghanistan
to be thrust back into that
which i did i kind of switched back into
that mode of being ready to fight
and do whatever was necessary to get us
out i'm a little bit choked up
that picture i believe was taken right
after i got off the phone with my kids
i think i started to have a panic attack
jason reached out took my hand and
started to comfort me then i'll never
forget
on his part have any of you sought
therapy
the tools that my therapist has given me
to deal with
the trauma that has helped me
tremendously
it is important to share with people
that
that trauma takes a toll and that there
is
help out there that there's no shame
in asking for help or having difficult
conversations
for those of us who were people of color
there were different reactions so take
off your member pin
i know i made a conscious decision as
did many of us
to leave the member pin on because it
was the decision
of do you want to be recognized by the
insurrectionist or what happens if you
take it off and you're not recognized by
capitol police and so
there were these beautiful moments in
the group where
there was a recognition of an experience
that we didn't have
but that was the first time in my life
that me
personally was on the receiving end of
the violence
of racism in our country and and since
that
it has allowed me to understand it in a
more visceral sense
instead of just up here also here where
does the
gallery group go from here it's been a
really meaningful group to have
and a wonderful support network i'll
bring a pie to the next gathering
promises promises we have a lot of
inside jokes out of that
jason never brings the pies well you can
see they are a very
tight-knit group and even though they're
all democrats some have tried to
dialogue with republicans
what's interesting is that this goes
beyond therapy now they consult each
other
on just about anything whether that's
legislation or the latest january six
actions like the select committee that
was announced last week jamie
a stronger bond nicole thank you every
time you look at those pictures though
guys it just
it really does take you back to that day
and i keep thinking these were americans
against other americans i can't get over
that
that shot of them of jason crowe holding
susan wilde's hand
i remember that very vividly i'll never
forget i think sometimes we forget when
you look at congress people these are
people
exactly right backgrounds that
compounded trauma and now
exactly you know what do you do with it
what's so terrifying is the complete
collapse of order
and just like that very order regimented
there's a process you're in congress and
then gone at the union capital at the
u.s capitol
i'm glad they have each other i'm glad
they also have pie
well it does make everything better
congressman please bring